[Music]
you are watching i'd like to know my
name is c.a murray and i'm in the
company of pastor daniel miranda
colleague and friend here at secret
sunsear and some tv daniel good to have
you here it is a pleasure to be with you
here in one of my favorite programs yeah
this is our favorite program daniel gets
to have a favorite program in two
languages
sadly i am i'm remanded to english and
english only
i can only respect and appreciate what
he and pastor board do in
spanish also but this is one of our
favorite programs because it gives us
the opportunity
to do a number of things another
one of the things that it does is it it
takes us back to the word a place where
we love to be and also it gives us an
opportunity to know and to understand
and appreciate the kinds of things that
are being discussed outside of secret
sunset and some tv what are the
questions that people have some of the
questions that we get
don't occur to us to be questions and
and some of the things that we have uh
are things that are shared by others
around the world so when the questions
come in we know what's in your mind uh
in your heart and what you would like to
know so it gives us a focus to our study
and we like to do that
let me say here we promise to give you
an answer from the word of the lord we
we say this often but it is true that we
are at such a point in earth's history
that it's a little late
to be
bantering about
the ideas of men and actually a couple
of the questions we have today kind of
deal with some some uh
man-made kinds of things that have been
added to the word of god are questions
that have come
so we need to give you answers from the
word of god because
the word of god is the only thing that
can help you that can inspire you that
can inform you and indeed can save you
that's what you need to spend your time
ruminating on listening to the word of
god not the opinions of men so we
promise to give you an answer from the
word of god if an answer from the word
of god can be found we will try to do
just that should you like to get in on
the fun should you want to be part of
this program you can do so very easily
by sending your questions to
tv at some tv dot o r g that is
tv
at some tv
dot o
r g and we will get to them just as
quickly as we can we have an impressive
pile here with us there are two other
piles i have in my drawer and i know you
have the same yes that i didn't even
bring on on the set today
so there are a lot of questions but we
always want more no questions no program
so we like to have the questions because
it focuses us and gives us a chance to
answer your your your questions
daniel if you would please lead us in
prayer then we'll sort of launch out
into our first question for you my
pleasure absolutely
let's spa heads for prayer
they are heavenly father which are in
heaven we come before your awesome
throne thanking you for this program
thanking you for the brethren who have
sent their questions
and as we seek to find answers in your
word i pray that your spirit may guide
our minds that we may only say what is
revealed in your word in the name of
jesus we pray amen amen amen
so daniel i think our first question
comes to us from maurice
and let me ask again
if you will
when you send in your questions
put in a little note where you are
writing us from we we can tell by some
of the names where some of the questions
are coming from but
it's interesting to know
where on planet earth you are and where
the questions are coming from so we
don't have a a country
or a continent for maurice but it's a
good question and um then you want to
sort of read it and sort of walk us
through it yes
so the question is how am i to harmonize
the signs of the times june 9
the first sentence
and testimonies for the church volume 2
page
third sentence with the statement that
the nature of christ was paused for
a fallen sinful nature
we try to did our research
we were not um sure if what we found was
exactly the sentence that the brother
was talking about
but we see a relationship between two
quotes for example the one
that is found in in testimonies for the
church that i like to read
and i i believe you have the one from
science of the times
this one comes
from page 508
and it says
speaking about jesus
he was insulted with corruption
a stranger to sin
yet he prayed and that often with strong
cry and tears he prayed for his
disciples and for himself thus
identifying himself with our needs our
weaknesses and our failings which are so
common with humanity
he was a mighty petitioner not
possessing the passions of our human
fallen natures but compassed with like
infirmities
tempted in all points even as we are
jesus endured agony which required help
and support from his father so i believe
the points that he wants to highlight
here is that here
it seems to say that he did not have the
same fascism of falling human beings
he was unsolid with corruption a
stranger to sin
not possessing the passions of our human
fallen natures
well said
let me add this reading from
signs of times this is june 9 1898.
um
there's a bunch of places i could start
let's go here what a site was this for
heaven to look upon christ who knew not
the least taint of sin
or defilement
took our nature in its deteriorated
condition
this was humiliation greater than
infinite man can comprehend
um
going back one paragraph
in assuming humanity christ took
the part of every human being
he was the head of humanity so in this
sense he he is representative not of any
individual human being but of all human
beings right
so
your reading mentioned
something and i want to add to that just
a little bit when we talk about the
nature of christ
we're dealing with with two specific
lines of thought one is propensity the
other is infirmity
ellen white is
clear that he took on the infirmities in
other words he didn't come with the
weaknesses
uh
he did come rather with the weaknesses
of humanity you know i was reading
something just a little bit and doing
some research
um
illinois says that adam had 20 times the
vital force we have 20 times she says if
he didn't the race would have pretty
much died out long ago that's through
through bad habits through disease
through eating the way we treat our
bodies
uh we have we have wasted so much of
that so if adam wasn't much stronger
than we are
uh the race would have just peeted out
well christ came
generation after generation after
generation down that line he didn't come
with the vital force of adam right he
came with the vital force of the people
in the times in which he lived
many many generations
down from adam so he didn't have
super human superman kind of kind of
strength
what he had was a nature what he had was
was a relationship with god
that was
intact he had what we
can have right so there's nothing he has
he had over us advantage-wise
i i you know i put this in a sermon just
a couple weeks ago
i was doing a wedding
and uh uh we were waiting for the uh uh
actually the groom was late the bride
was on time um and the church was was
being repaired and the walls were torn
down in my study and uh they had tape
turn turn out the sheet rocking us down
to the studs so a lot was exposed
somehow a a mouse got in in a sweater
pretty good sized mouse too
and i never seen a bunch of women move
that fast i mean that bride jumped up on
my desk and then she was up on the
credenza in two hops you know she got to
dress up and she was just
and uh there was a little boy there who
was the bible bear you know in some
countries they have a little boy caring
about it
white tuxedo
i don't know where that child got
but he when we finally found him the
white tuxedo was a black tuxedo i mean
he found some dirty hole to crawl into
and it was filthy well we the jacket was
so bad we just couldn't so he had to
walk in his shirt and his his pants you
know because the jackal was just it was
awful we just couldn't get it clean
um and so i i i thought in my to myself
is it easier daniel to get cleaned or to
stay clean
you know your parents put clean clothes
on you know say don't get those clothes
dirty
so you have to keep clean well christ
came clean
but then he had to stay clean right and
in in in some instances it's tougher to
stay clean even than to get clean you
know
there are those who will tell you when
they have had long drinking histories
it's one thing to get sober it's another
thing to stay sober you know um so
christ had the burden of staying clean
so he had all of the
temptations he had all of the the
pressures from satan that we have even
more because satan was constantly on him
yet he had to remain
unsullied and unclean uh he didn't come
with sin and he didn't pick up any along
the way praise god so now he can be he
can be my example amen amen praise the
lord yes you know this subject of the
nature of christ is is very complex
because we have some quotes that
apparently say that he took the pre-fall
human nature
other quotes
show
that he took the postfall human nature
and even today the church is split and
divided into this issue of the human
nature of christ uh our ministry has
recorded
plenty of presentations dealing with
this subject yes so
we will not uh deal with it thoroughly
right now but we will
go to what is most important what is
most important is that and this is clear
and i think both sides agree
that we can all overcome as jesus
overcame amen i mean he came and lived a
cinder's life he gave us an example
of how to live a life dependent on god
on our fallen human nature and we too
can be can overcome as he overcame
we have grace available
to
pardon our sins and to give us a
victorious life and as you said that's
the most difficult part amen to stay
clear clean and but jesus stayed clean
and and we can stay killing through his
grace amen and amen
one last line the majesty of heaven
undertook the cause of man and with the
same facilities
that man may obtain so christ didn't
have access to anything that we do not
have and cannot have access to
that man may obtain withstood the
temptations of satan as a man must
withstand them
this was the only way in which fallen
man could become partakers of the divine
nature in taking human nature christ was
fitted to understand man's trials and
sorrows and all the temptations
wherewith he is beset amen yes amen what
a beautiful promise beautiful beautiful
promise
all righty question number two
is this the long one from victor yes so
we have here actually four questions in
one and we'll we'll try to do our best
if not
we can leave the questions that uh are
an answer for our next program
uh this one comes from victor and he
says hi i'm victor from nairobi kenya
from nairobi i've been to nairobi thanks
to you my brother
i followed the program on
some tv ardently
and it is such a blessing i also happen
to have watched the entire series of
cracking the genesis code and i must
admit that without a doubt
it is the most eye-opening and
convincing study of scripture i have
ever laid my hands on
bard bible and the lngi writings
keep up the good work
and then here are his questions question
number one
is the seven thousand year principle
biblical
and should we look forward to its
fulfillment
the one that says that god operates in
sevens divided into six and ones
that god worked for six day six days and
rested on the seventh day for one day
and if so we are to go to heaven for one
thousand years
for the earth to rest then we would have
to stay on earth for exactly 6 000 years
counted from the time sin entered the
world to the second coming
of jesus
so basically this question is about the
theory of the 6 000 years of sin
that ellen white alludes
i've heard a lot about this lately yes
so what are your thoughts faster well
you say she alludes to and i think
that's a good use of the terminology
when she discusses it she discusses it
in fairly broad terms and i found just a
little bit ago about 90 times
where she uses that there's a lot yeah
so she says it a lot so that's what we
excuse me that's where we get it from i
don't know if we can call it a hard and
fast biblical principle but it is an
understanding of the working of god with
man kind that we see worked out in
scripture right
when she says six thousand years now
there are times when she says about six
thousand years there are the times when
she just flat says six thousand years
she doesn't mean six thousand years as
opposed to six thousand and one years or
six thousand years and six months so
she's not laying out a hard period of
time right what she is doing is exposing
a general pattern of time with which sin
has had sway in the world which is with
which god has dealt with his people
so it's not a uh and that that's why i
sort of push back a little against the
word principle because it's not a hard
period of time although it is a general
beard if it's 650 or 6055
or maybe six thousand and one hundred
it's still about six thousand years that
this uh sin problem has been played out
and that's what she's uh alluding to
we know we're going to spend a thousand
years
in
in in heaven and then of course satan is
chained during our time and then we come
back so when you add your six and one
you get seven again
not
hardcore but about
seven thousand years in total right
so
um i have a few things that i want to
say about this first of all i've heard
some theories and i'd like to begin with
that
that people i would say they're sincere
and they want to find answers to these
uh overwhelming evidence
as you said about 90 times ellen white
mentions this and this has awakened the
interest of some
scholars and some bible students some of
them have concluded based on this
that jesus is coming in the year
2027.
others have concluded that jesus is
coming in the year 2031.
why is that well some use the quote by
ellen white where she says that when
jesus was baptized
about 4 000 years
had elapsed
so since jesus when he was baptized in
year 27 a.d
you know you have 4 000 years there
then you just add 2 000 more and that
takes you to 2027.
[Laughter]
now
um the ones that put the date to set the
date for 2031 they are based on another
quote by the same author yes where she
says that on the cross
four thousand years have
passed
right and so if on the cross that was
year 31
it takes you to 2031.
but
she also says that when jesus was born
four thousand years had elapsed so
what am i trying to say and i'm just
seconding what you just mentioned
ellen why when she gives this time
period especially this these ones yes
four thousand two thousand six thousand
she's working with approximates
but she's not setting a fixed period of
time
because the bible doesn't give us that
the bible gives us a set period of seven
days a week yeah the bible talks about
the seven
um
years
that the seventh year the rest that the
earth was to rest
so
but that we don't have but the bible
talks about the jubilee the 50 years
yeah but the bible doesn't give us the
rule of
uh six thousand and the seventh thousand
a year i mean
we might have we might come to some
conclusions based on this but the point
is
yes this is an approximation
and even if it were true
we don't have the date
when the sin enter into the world
precisely so even if this were true and
if we if we would take it as a literal
exact six thousand years one no day more
nor day less
still
we don't have the date
when sin enter now some people are
speculating and are they're saying oh
you know jesus was the second adam and
you know jesus died at the age of 30 or
he was uh
at the age of 31 33 he's at the age of
30 he started his ministry so adam must
have fallen because he's the first adam
he must have fallen by the same time he
he lived a sinless sinless life as jesus
did on earth so anyways
um
this is i would say uh something that
the lord has not given us clear light
and we should be careful how we treat
the six thousand years yeah i
i would ask that and well said daniel um
ellen white is not trying to be a
historian right it's not her job nor is
that her what she's trying to give you
is the the the prophetic map uh the the
layout of the land as it were so that we
know
that we are in the the last days of this
earth history that's that's what you
draw from all of this
the lord has in mercy hidden certain
things from us we know not the day nor
the hour uh and we don't know and and
won't know until just before it happens
and there's a reason for that because of
uh the slothfulness of of mankind
because of our predilection to try to go
right to the edge and then sort of come
back and and sort of play games with god
so there are certain dates certain
things certain events that god does not
lock down for us so you cannot say all
right we go to the cross
back up 4 000 years and you know exactly
the date that eve pulled the fruit from
detroit it doesn't work that
way because it wasn't it wasn't intended
to
we we have a general what we do know
is that the history of this earth
particularly mankind's existence on this
earth it's not millions of years it's
not billions of years is not what the
scientists try to push down our throats
that has been going on for a long long
long long time we know that is not so
but it's not necessary to our salvation
to know exactly the date it started what
we need to live each day as
uh is as
it were our last day and that is another
day to draw closer to jesus christ and
that's the overall theme that i think
she's trying to promote here amen amen
okay so i think we have time to answer
this is one more question from our
brother our brother victor
the second question of his four
questions is why is the study of the
seventh-day adventists
who have
kept the law consciously being in the
special resurrection
that happens just before jesus comes
not as widely taught and preached in our
churches
especially as a motivation to preach
teach live and died in the third angel's
message as i believe
it can be so his question is why is it
that
our understanding of the special
resurrection is not preached in our
churches as it should
one of the things that i would i would
say is
i think as a a
mode of preaching
historically we have not focused on that
we have focused on being ready for jesus
we've looked at the the the general
resurrection we have looked at
uh first thessalonians 4 16 for the lord
shall descend from heaven with a shout
and we get the sequence there
also we haven't really laid on as much
as we
possibly could
the 144 thousand
one is because there's some debate as to
make up mm-hmm and and in some places
strong debate yes and uh
the same with the special resolute
resurrection what we've said as a church
rather than
uh enter in those kind of debates be
prepared for the second coming of christ
whenever it happens whatever
whatever
class you fall into
that's really god's decision
don't strive for a particular class
strive to be right with god amen and
then let god make that decision and that
that's the general theme that we've
carried uh as a church throughout our
all our years yeah and especially
because the topic of the special
resurrection which is very dear to as a
seventh-day adventist
it is not a fundamental belief of our
church
uh and it is not widely
i mean we not it's not like the sabbath
or our or
the other doctrines that we have yeah
that you can see them from genesis to
revelation
but um this topic about the special
resurrection is just one small aspect
of
of the the state of the death yes that
that we have our doctrine yes so
i believe that's why some preachers have
not really touched this very much some
others may not have the understanding i
cannot speak for others yes but
um whenever i have the opportunity and
i'm teaching or
preaching about daniel or revelation 14
13. i mentioned this
but
i don't make this my
my overall theme yes yes
there are certain kinds of things
pastor that are more
shall i say
pedagogical more academic
they are not really rubber meets the
road kinds of things
what you want to wake up each morning
saying to yourself is am i in jesus name
are my sins forgiven
am i following everything that i know to
be right am i eschewing or getting away
from everything that i know to be wrong
is jesus the lord of my life
if you are answering those questions in
the affirmative
you are where god wants you to be yes
whether you make it as part of the
hundred and fourth of a thousand whether
you go to sleep before christ comes or
are awake when he comes and as part of
the debate
uh or uh part of the the special
resurrection is really secondary to your
walk with jesus christ uh and if you you
map that out in your life and you are
right with christ uh then then you're
where you walk amen
and and i agree uh with the brother that
says that yes
this can be a great motivation but
that should not be our
special motivation
either i like what you said either i i'm
part of the 144 thousand
or if i resurrect the special
resurrection
all i want to be is with jesus yes yes
so it doesn't at the end our greatest
motivation should be jesus christ to be
with him
uh to inherit eternal life and be with
jesus the rest of our lives amen and
that should be what what should move us
and jesus is the center he is the
greatest motivation he's the greatest
magnet that draws us to him amen amen
the thing that really motivates me is
the love of christ you know and illinois
tells us if you spend a little time each
day thinking about the the great
condescending
the great sacrifice that ought to
embolden you
and certainly give you courage and
strength to face the trials of the day
and if that is true then that ought to
be the basis of our preaching yes your
love for jesus your relationship with
jesus you know first john tells me i
don't know that i have eternal life well
if you ought to know uh if you need to
know then you need to have reasons for
that knowledge and one is your
relationship with christ and the the
more you lift up christ
the humbler makes you and the more it
makes you want to serve him not
necessarily that you're part of a
particular group but that you are
following the lord and serving him so
that's a great thing
yes
already our time has fast slipped into
eternity it goes so very very fast in
these last 40 seconds or so a closing
thought daniel and then we'll wrap it up
well uh we'll continue with the
questions from brother victor we still
have two more left
and i hope if you're watching that you
can stay tuned and watch our next
program we'll continue with your
questions
yeah victor you actually get two shows
[Music]
you